you know I think we've got a lot of
scientists working in the United States
certainly already would we like to have
more funding of course everybody wants
more funding for their particular area
you know if I were in the theater I
demand more government funding for you
know theater productions so yeah more
money would be nice but i think the the
real role that the president can play
and in this this broader kind of theme
of science literacy is in education
using the presidency as a bully pulpit
to get out the message that science is
important it's not just something that's
done by the scientists for the
scientists it's done by the scientists
who are citizens for everybody else in
the country and it with the
collaboration of everybody else in the
country because at least in terms of
government supported science it's paid
for by the rest of the country so you
know I think scientists have a role to
play as well I think scientists should
perhaps make more of an effort to
communicate with the public at large
about the work they're doing and the
implications and why it's important you
know it's it's perhaps easier to ask for
more money than it is to explain to
people who don't have a scientific
background why you need more money but I
think the latter is at least as
important and you know it's these days
of my opinion part of being a a
scientist irresponsible scientist